bonsoir mais en soi choquant si merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on l'a entendue dans ce sujet certains
estiment que le dernier sommet du g 500
en mettant la pression sur les armées
locales auraient pu conduire un
directement à ces agissements ça vous
paraît être une bonne analyse
absolument pas je pense que c'est une
analyse qui est et honte et qui n'est
pas conforme à la réalité
le g5 c'est là pour mission de faire une
guerre de contre guérilla pour n'a
absolument pas avaliser des modes
d'action qui ne soit pas acceptable au
niveau du droit international ou
humanitaires donc il est un petit peu
simpliste de rattacher à cette
conférence internationale ailleurs
pilotée par la france des exactions sur
le terrain de troupes manifestement
plutôt mal commandé mal contrôlée comme
d'ailleurs c'est souvent le cas dans
toutes les actions de contre guérilla
dans les pays africains ou ailleurs ça
pose donc la question selon vous au
principalement de la formation de ses
forces armées de leur management entre
nîmes et oui tout à fait mais il faut
pas se faire d'illusions toutes les
armes et aujourd'hui reçoivent des cours
de droit international de respect des
populations de respect des conventions
de genève
ça c'est le premier point maintenant ce
sont des cours avec une application sur
le terrain en temps de paix en temps de
guerre
et ce qui est le cas justement dans
cette zone sahélienne nous sommes dans
une des actions de guérilla bien entendu
d'ailleurs c'est dit dans le rapport un
rapport comme qui ne fait que 20 pages
ce rapport dit bien que ce sont plutôt
des réactions de troupeaux qui ont
étaient attaqués ou d'individus de
militaires réguliers qui ont été
attaqués et qui ont effectivement aurait
plutôt mener des actions de représailles
voilà bah c'est le cas dans toutes les
guerres c'est regrettable c'est
condamnable
le quai d'orsay s'est très bien exprimé
sur la question ces actions ne sont pas
tolérables maintenant en quoi faute et
toutes les prouver et puis aussi
peut-être un peu comprendre le contexte
mais ça ne se justifie pas on imagine
effectivement quand vous évoquez
au climat de tension qui doit régner sur
le terrain ah oui tout à fait mais
aujourd'hui cette guerre elle dure cette
guerre pèse de toute façon sur les
populations
les populations sont l'enjeu ce soit
pour les gouvernements locaux ou pour
les groupes terroristes
si vous reprenez le rapport d'amnesty
international il ya trois lignes sur les
groupes terroristes
il serait intéressant de savoir
exactement quels sont les exactions
qu'on connaît qui ont été commises
contre les populations par ces groupes
terroristes
or l'objet de ce rapport tel que moi je
les lui montrent que la cible ce sont
les états qui mènent la guerre contre
les terroristes et pas vraiment les
groupes terroristes
oui effectivement amnesty dit il
faudrait les poursuivre on sait bien
qu'on n'avait pas les poursuivre donc
c'est une attaque en règle finalement
compté gouvernement et je pense que ce
rapport est un petit peu inégal dans son
approche
en quoi est-elle inégale il était né
gueule parce qu'il met la pression sur
les gouvernements ce cas les limite peut
se comprendre mais il demande au
gouvernement d'agir
bon un grand terrain ne peut agir mais
cette guerre de terrorisme me met quand
même aux prises des groupes armés qui
massacrent les populations
c'est une réalité et qui ont massacré de
grandes quantités de population donc à
la limite si ce rapport avait bien
d'établir les faits de part et d'autre
pour les condamnés d'une avec la même
rigueur le même jugement
je pense que ce rapport serait tout à
fait acceptable en l'état
moi tels que je les lui la tel quel ce
que vous avez présenté il ya quelques
instants sur un analyste d'amnesty
international mais montrent une certaine
partialité qui est assez courante
d'ailleurs dans ce type de rapport où on
met en cause d'abord les états avant de
ceux qui sont la cause des massacres
pour l'occurrence ici des groupes
terroristes
avec évidemment le danger de
décrédibiliser l'armée les armées
locales voulaient dire sans doute un oui
mais bon les armées locales comme dans
tout pays en guerre et ces pays
africains ne sont pas toujours bien
accepté
il est certain que malgré des années de
formation dans ces armes et on voit bien
que tous les ce qu'on a
pendant un accident tel n'est pas
appliquée que ça on le sait ensuite ce
sont désarmés qui sont mis sous pression
depuis des années qui ont subi des
pertes importantes notamment au mali qui
n'ont pas forcément monter une grande
rigueur dans l'action militaire et qui
finalement sont dans une situation un
petit peu de déséquilibre face à un
ennemi agressif face à des populations
qui subissent une guerre
et puis la recherche de ces terroristes
qu'il faut détruire et dans toute guerre
civile parce que disons les choses
telles qu'elles sont ce sont des guerres
civiles en brodant le dans leur principe
la recherche du renseignement
les représailles malheureusement font
partie de ce genre de guerre même s'il
faut les dénoncer
même s'il faut condamner les auteurs
c'est une réalité qu'on ne peut pas
balayer d'un revers de main merci
beaucoup général françois chavance y
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france